hallo im sind cdu-direktkandidat sie
sind aber auch musikmanager und wann mal
sänger einer crossover metal band sind
sie nicht viel zu cool für die cdu ich
finde die cdu eine coole partei
[Musik]
was ja auch ganz interessant ist und
irgendwie auch ganz lustig ist dass sie
auch musikmanager der kelly family sind
ja was glauben sie ist die größere
herausforderung das comeback der kelly
family oder das comeback von armin
laschet
also
[Gelächter]
das sind zwei unterschiedliche
voraussetzungen
armin laschet ist on the way da ist nix
mit comeback
der ministerpräsident von nordrhein
westfalen er kreist ein bundesland aber
lassen wir uns nicht über laschet reden
und das ist cool setzte auf jeden fall
sie waren früher mal bei den grünen
interessanterweise vertreten jetzt die
politik der cdu sie sind so ein bisschen
wie winfried kretschmann kann man sagen
nur dass sie sich geoutet haben oder
es ist ein lustiges bild auf jeden fall
danke ich bin ja heute hier weil ich
will ja helfen ich möchte sie
unterstützen die cdu braucht die hilfe
ich biete mich an danke was kann ich tun
also erstmal danke beihilfe ist immer
willkommen ja und die werden wir nicht
ausschlagen
[Musik]
hallo hier gibt es den besten kuchen der
stadt der mann weiß wie man schreit nein
das ist wirklich so sehr habe ich euch
das mal anbieten das wäre super nett
kennen sie den mann wählen kennen sie
schon und wer ist das ja jetzt sich
drauf haben
den namen können die leute aber die
partei kennen sie
die haben wir doch gekauft vorher nein
ich hab ich habe hier noch ich war oft
hier die cdu will ja vor allem die
gutverdiener entlasten erzählen sie das
auch in dem sogar gesprächen wir wollen
eine starke wirtschaft für deutschland
beibehalten aber es sind vor allem die
gutverdiener die
die profitieren
also meine regierung wird er gebildet
aus koalitionsverhandlungen und es wird
niemals die cdu alleine regieren da
werden also noch andere hoffnung auf die
koalition mit einer vernünftigen
warum ist das natürlich realistisch
sehen und ein bisschen gas geben wie ich
das noch mal nicht mit dem schlafwagen
zum genau kein schlafwagen waren
schlafwagen wahlkampf dann gehen sie
denn wählen gehen sie wählen jetzt
machen sie keinen fehler wir sind kurz
davor steht kurz davor ja ich weiß also
nie überlege immer noch ob ich wählen
mein nein sie müssen wählen ich weiß
aber das ist keine alternative ich kenne
sie nicht ich will jetzt gegen nicht
gegen sie sagen aber
ihre politischen leitfiguren wie
meinen sie
früher war ich mal grün aber ist alles
was
du dir mal grün da gibt es eine
gemeinsamkeit also wer grün sind die ich
habe doch schon ja er war
ja aber das ist trauriger die grünen
sind ja auch nie merken ja er ja auch
nicht das ist es auch wir haben wir
haben die freunde hier wird
nicht weil sie nicht die cdu wissen sie
schon wen sie
problem
jetzt ist die zeit für den wechsel
danke das freut mich sehr aber was ist
dann am ehesten seiner partei
kommandeurs hier
tatsächlich weiterer fehler gemacht
ich würde mir das auf jeden fall die
tierschutzpartei weil ich selber für den
tierschutz und
dann nennen sie respekt respekt müssen
sie müssen aber zur einigung hat ja man
hat falsche halt nein ich finde man muss
wirklich die meinung des gegenübers
respektieren ja was ist das personal
transporter als wenig kreativ
das ist kein wahlkampf was ist dann muss
man jetzt zu beweisen muss man das so
sieht wie stehen sie zur cannabis
legalisierung macht bringt dich dann zu
mir mama da bringt sich daher zu mir
etwas auf die programme würde sagen ich
wähle die cdu jetzt lassen wir müssen
noch mal praktisch wir können die kamera
auch ausmachen sie sind doch in ried
management sie haben das zeug doch eine
andere weise zu hause das tun sie doch
nicht so als wenn die kelly family nicht
naja wie kam nicht ewig zeit wählst du
wäre es ihnen jetzt oder nicht gehen
jetzt mal hier lies dir das mal wo ich
bringe dann nimm deinen freunden noch
mal was mir deinen koffer freude vielen
dank die ja ja ja das gespräch dank für
das gespräch und wünschen noch einen
schönen tag alles klar
sie sind musikproduzent haben sich schon
mal über einen balkon nachgedacht ja
habe ich tatsächlich aber wenn sie jetzt
einen walzer komponieren würden noch mal
welche worte müssten vorkommen
freiheit freiheit
zukunft zukunft liebe freiheit zukunft
lieber da der song ist doch fertig
jetzt
hier wie es unser song nochmal liebe
zukunft die saison liebe zu rissen
einmal zukunft zukunft freiheit liebe
entschuldigung
da habe ich kurz was mit ihnen singen
kommt auch an wenn du meine chance
kennst kannst du freestyle was meinst du
mit riester also einfach mal
improvisieren sagt ihr zum beispiel
liebe freiheit zukunft und aus diesen
drei wörtern machst du gerade das was du
so vieles was wir gerade in den sinn
kommen liebe freiheit zu kommen
[Musik]
liebe
2 hat
freiheit und
liebe
freiheit
ist für alle da
[Musik]
aber
ihnen ist schon bewusst dass weizen
wahlwerbespot für die cdu können sie
damit leben ok
erst ob sie gegen die sache ist man ohne
sas kennst du dieses symbol
was ist das das ist ein balkany
das ist das zeichen der anarchistischen
pogo-partei deutschlands
ja krass oder es ist einfach mal der
plattenboss der kelly familie
wir kennen nicht die kelly family ernst
gut da sehe ich jetzt alle ihre großen
hits und zwar so lange bis ihr den kanal
abonniert haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]